[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 my name is 2020 Metro class
champion Caleb Denby and today I will be
your driver on this journey of course
I'm referring to the Metro class
championship which just took place at
the club somehow none of these Sloot and
Webster GM's made it out for the day
so they gave one to me finally think of
these sick of these college kids coming
in and take it away all the titles so
today I actually wanted to look at a
couple games from that tournament and
one game from a tournament a while ago
and I wanted to go over how you should
kind of be analyzing your own game so
what kind of process you can go through
to analyze your own games and to try and
improve from them whether or not you won
or lost there's always going to be
mistakes there's always going to be room
for improvement unless you're playing
like the game of your life so just
jumping into it here in round one I was
paired against Alex Jiang who is a very
talented kid from the st. Louis area
I think he's part of the Select chess
program that we started here for for
talented kids he's over 2,000 and he's
quite young so give him a couple years
I'm sure he'll be beating me but he was
my opponent for round one and he played
the ragazze in so Nate c3 I am black in
this game Bishop b4 and then there's a
few lines here for white you can play
Bishop g5 you can play something simple
like III or Queen a4 is is also a very
valid choice now quit a4 usually this is
not the way you want to play the opening
you know getting the Queen out early but
today well this will here rather this is
a special circumstance so of course this
is a fork of the king and the bishop and
after knight c6 maybe black isn't quite
ready to have this Knight here does
anybody know why black might not be
ready to have this knight on the season
yes exactly right just as a general rule
generally you want to develop your
nights behind your pawns because they do
really well at controlling the same
squares and putting a lot of pressure on
the enemy position and after Queen a 496
obviously you can't develop the night
behind the pawn that being said this
isn't all bad for black in fact because
white does spend some time bringing this
queen out to a4 and black does use that
time to to get developed while it might
not be the most ideal setup for black
the knight on c6 is still going to be a
powerful piece in particular while the
pressure on d4 is a little bit lessened
because we can't play c5 we now are
controlling ee5 that much more quickly
thanks to this Queen a4 move and so be
on the lookout
sometimes these dark squares in the
center kind of fall to black if white
isn't careful now white played Bishop g5
and I want to be honest with you I've
been slacking a bit on my opening theory
study and I I didn't know this position
I had no idea what was happening but you
know if you're not that's why if you've
seen the lecture don't memorize moves
understand your openings you should be
should be fine here and so I know a very
common idea in there it goes in is to
play h6
and force this bishop to make a decision
and a lot of the simpler lines come
after Bishop takes f6 and Queen takes f6
when a pair of pieces come off the board
black gets castled and then black place
for e5 and so this is kind of the way I
was expecting this game to go and then
my opponent kind of surprised me with
Bishop f4 and I didn't really understand
why my opponent had played like this
I thought h6 would be a useful move for
me and if he wanted to come to f4 he
could have done it on on the previous
turn and so I was sitting here for a
little bit now as I was thinking about
the position because this was a totally
fresh position to me turns out this is a
totally fresh position to the the lead
chess database as well so it's
definitely worth
stopping to take time in positions like
these so let's stop and think for a
little bit if you've never seen there
goes and it might be hard to come up
with the idea that I came up with in the
game if you are quite familiar with
there goes in you might be a little bit
more likely to to find the sequence of
moves that I played but I thought white
wasted quite a bit of time with Bishop
g5 to f4 any wasted some time with Queen
f4 as well and so I looked to find some
ways to take advantage of that so I'll
give you guys a minute to think about it
so I was slacking here didn't have the
YouTube chat open so we're gonna pull
that up see what they have to say okay
I got two moves what do you mean what
moves yeah okay so black could castle
here and you you would be unpinning the
knight but due to the way my opponent
has played he does have control over
this a five square so if I just simply
castle probably just developed with III
and it's gonna be a little bit tougher
for me to get a 5/3 because both of his
pieces are aimed at this square as well
as the D pawn of course Bishop d7 is not
a bad move at all but you kind of need a
reason behind this play and it turns out
already on move let's see what move it
is seven there were some very
interesting tactics going on D take c5
is being suggested I think they mean D
takes e4 and I actually don't like this
move so much so yeah maybe D takes e4 is
is okay but this wasn't the idea I was
thinking of probably white can just play
e3 and get this pawn back without too
much difficulty and once again it's
gonna be tough to challenge the center
with E 5 so the move I did play is
actually Bishop d7 and my opponent
played Queen c2 which is kind of wasting
more time
of course after e3 everybody loves this
tactic does everybody see the tactic
here everybody's favorite tactic
take d for hanging your bishop but you
get the fork yeah so this is the big
idea with Bishop d7 is it does make a
threat here and so after Queen c2 I
actually had this line prepared before I
played Bishop d7 but now this is kind of
the point of my play so once again let's
see if you guys can find the idea it's
not something simple like castles I
think black is okay after castles but
this control over the e5 square is
actually gonna be a little bit
unpleasant I think 94 it's like it's a
playable move but once again blacks just
gonna or White's just going to develop
there's there's not too much of a threat
here yeah
doubling doubling these pawns doesn't
really get the job done because this
pawn is gonna trade itself off on a on
d5 Knight h5 yeah that's close that's a
that's a good idea so if you play Knight
h5
probably Bishop g3 or a Bishop e5 I'm
not sure which one is better
maybe Bishop e5 yeah
so take stakes and this night is gonna
be powerful here and probably we have to
spend some time bringing the knight back
but Michael apron with the correct
answer I played g5 in this position and
you'll see this happens sometimes and
there it goes in and yeah the the reason
I play g5 here is one yes you get to
harass the bishop and two if the bishop
comes back to g3 trying to just kind of
save itself you're going to hit with g4
and then this pawn is actually still
under defended on on d4 so g5 is a very
forcing move and while it's kind of
unnatural it's still worth thinking
about the forcing moves even early on
and it turns out g5 was actually correct
here the bishop comes to e5 of course to
defend this pawn and now the line I had
calculated went g4 moves the knight of
course you cannot really take on f6 I'll
take back and take d4 so
- I now take on e5 takes on e5 and then
what's the big point at the end of the
line if you don't play this move you're
gonna be significantly worse well you
don't have quite enough defense of that
square yet even if you take off this
piece then I mean even pond tix could be
playable
I think context might be played
yeah d4 is exactly right so this is kind
of the point at the end of the day you
have the bishop pair and while white
does have this advanced pawn on d5 you
have this advanced pawn on d4 and it's
actually quite awkward to to move this
Knight anywhere you're not going to you
you definitely don't really want to come
to me for I'm simply going to capture
this this is pinned so you have to take
back with the Queen and now there's all
sorts of uncomfortable business
happening happening even after for
example Queen g5 and something like
Queen side castles yeah you're getting a
little bit killed here on the D 2 square
so 94 not really gonna be ideal for
Wyatt and so my opponent played 91 kind
of stepping back now of course my knight
is attacked
so I played Knight aged 5 and the
difficulty here is kind of evaluating
whether or not all of this was worth it
for black or not you know just because
you can doesn't mean you should so what
what do you think is is was all this
worth it in the end for the black player
here what do we have and in this
position
yeah yeah that's that's it's it's kind
of true I think it was worth it for
black as well you were mentioning you
know you put the bishop on c6 maybe
Castle queenside the point in this
position that I want to talk about
obviously both sides have glaring
weaknesses both sides of have
crazy-crazy pawn structures but at the
end of the day White's pieces are bad
and blacks pieces have squares right
this Bishop on b4 is eyeing this Knight
it'll probably get kicked away but it
can drop back to e7 this Bishop can come
to c6 and this Knights threatening to
come to f4 yeah and so if for example
white wants to stop the knight from
coming to f4 we even have the f5 square
as well for the night so blacks pieces
have squares and whites pieces kind of
don't for the moment you know this efore
square might might become a good a good
asset for white but for the moment he
doesn't really have any squares in the
game my opponent played III which I
think was a bit of a mistake actually
white probably had to attack this Bishop
right away undo this pin and start
trying to get this Knight into into e4
instead though III and now this gives me
a little bit of time to uh to work
things out black has a variety moves
here that are all very good
I chose Bishop c6 like you were saying
it just puts the bishop on a nice square
with the added bonus of allowing this
Queen to I the d4 pawn as well
now a3 from my opponent and when I was
looking at this game afterwards the
engine actually recommended I captured
on d2 but I like looked at it and looked
at it looked at it and I'm just I'm
never gonna take on d2 here so I can't
in good conscience I felt like you know
I should let you know that Bishop takes
d2 is what they're claiming to be the
best move but it's it's pretty unnatural
actually to it to give up the bishop
like this
the line might continue something like
takes on e3 and then there's problems
like Knight f4 and this pawn is weak and
black is still more developed but I
liked fish would be 7 a lot better
instead you just keep the bishop on the
board and you have plenty of
opportunities to jump in to the attack
b4 was my opponent's choice and now is
when you kind of have to stop and and
calculate here with black so black has a
number of options the move that I chose
was actually a little bit incorrect but
I'll let you try and find the the
winning line here you do have a winning
line
and it's actually not too complicated I
saw the line in the game but I was
worried about a particular response from
white that's what made me not play it
although I suppose if I if I had no
worries than I would have just played it
so
hmm five doesn't doesn't make a ton of
sense you you really you're you're
asking for some trouble on the g6 square
yeah and then what's the idea what if
just Knight takes Bishop c5 is actually
nice strengthening move here but you
just you just have a simple fork here
right everybody sees Queen d4 attacks
the rook and attacks upon their arc has
to move and after Queen takes e5 black
is just up upon and now these moves like
f5 are actually gonna be coming through
without this EEP on to kind of hinder
the black pieces Bishop g5 as well and
this night it's gonna come under a lot
of pressure the move I was worried about
though was I thought maybe my opponent
could get away with F takes a here
guarding the d4 square but of course
what is the response to F takes E
yeah Bishop h4 check and for some reason
in my head I thought g3 was playable
here but of course you can simply yeah
take on g3 first check and then you get
the rook in the end so I of course
should have just taken on e3 immediately
but you know I thought Bishop h4 I'll
pin this F pawn first and then you can
take a III afterwards so well now I mean
g3 has the same problem and I actually
noticed this time what my opponent
played though is actually the the best
response and that was with b5 and I
thought at first that he just kind of
calculated badly or maybe didn't
calculate at all that happens sometimes
too but of course now this this kind of
lets me break through with my idea I
just take on e3 taking on c6 is not
going to be ideal for white you're
giving up this knight in return and
losing a couple pawns or at least one
pawn in the exchange so my opponent
played Knight takes c3 and then I played
Queen d4 and now if you notice it's the
same threat except now this Knight is a
under attack as well threatened
threatened to be captured in the game
my opponent looked very defeated in and
gave up and played B takes c6
and I took on a1 and and the game was
was over shortly but once I played Queen
d4 I had a moment of panic where I was
like wait a second he can just play the
move that you all see what move is that
No instead of white taking the bishop
here well if he moves the rook I'll take
the knight I'm pinning the King if only
there were some moving chess that moves
both the king and the rook at the same
time yes the white can castle here and
black still has a nice advantage after
Bishop takes f2 renewing the threat to
the knight but takes takes takes takes
and it's definitely not the winning
position that I thought I had yeah back
to here so Knight be three of course
there are two threats in the position
one is this one which you were solving
with Knight B 3 the other one is to take
this Knight using this pin so night b3
unfortunately does lose the night but
yeah in the game my opponent just took
on c6 in the game it did quickly of
course castling would have been the the
crazy save in the position for for white
here what's the the takeaway from this
game though well for black I guess the
point is black being me in this case
it's worth spending a bit more time
calculating of course laziness is
actually a huge problem for a lot of
chess players and I don't mean laziness
and like studying you know outside of
the tournament you know getting
well-prepared for the for the tournament
doing tactics every day now the kind of
laziness I'm talking about is laziness
at the board which is something I've
talked about a little bit you get to the
to the chess board and you're playing
your chess game and you think you see a
winning line and then it's very tempting
just to play it and see what happens
you know yet or not calculating
thoroughly enough even and so it's just
kind of a wake up call
that's you really do need to spend the
extra time to calculate so you don't get
surprised at the board after playing you
know your winning line with with
queenside castle out of nowhere it's not
good to be missing these kinds of moves
and so
that was I think my big mistake in the
game is not calculating well enough to
notice queenside castles and especially
not calculating well enough in this
position to realize I can just take care
immediately you know that Queen d4 is
unstoppable and so as always even in
games which you win there are going to
be mistakes
if only mistakes and you're thinking
even if they don't appear on the board
and so you want to be pretty critical
about that kind of thing and keep an eye
on it make sure you're you're doing
you're doing everything you should be at
the chess board so from from blacks
point of view yeah that the only problem
I really saw what this game is is being
a bit too lazy at the board with white
on the other hand there are a few things
to keep an eye on one is you know if you
don't know the opening super well you
really just need to rely on those
principles so Bishop g5 and moving the
bishop back already this is what gives
black this this nice little edge that we
saw in the game where he can push on the
Kings side with g5 and g4 and then get
this big central d4 upon that really
cramps white that was mistake number one
and then I think from there once he kind
of had this bad position he kind of just
crumbled and it's really really annoying
to try to play bad positions like this
but if you're gonna you know score those
extra half points and your tournaments
if you're really you know caring about
each and every half point that you get
this is a position where if I had the
white pieces I would spend a crazy
amount of time here just thinking
looking at all the options trying to
find some way to create problems for my
opponent and III definitely isn't that
move in fact I think my opponent played
III rather quickly so when you find
yourself on the back foot like this this
is when you need to kind of double down
and try and find the absolute best way
to to cause problems for your opponent
even if you're not playing the best
moves you want to play problematic moves
moves that give your opponent the chance
to slip up a little bit
so yeah 83 and then at the end of the
day yeah the the final mistake is kind
of this b5 move without calculating and
then of course after Queen B for taking
the bishop instead of clean side castles
just once again I think there's just
some reluctance to put in the maximum
effort and and what he assumed was a
losing position any questions on this
game with with Alex here all right well
yeah but when you're in such a bad
position like this
you can't play just the natural move
intuitively because when you're so far
behind in development in space that you
need to be developing absolutely
correctly rather than just you know
developing at all you know I like to say
sometimes in what white hasn't done
anything wrong so white can't be worse
but white has done a lot wrong already
so you can no longer just simple simply
develop to maintain some kind of balance
[Music]
so yeah we're moving on here to Game two
of the Metro clash championship I was
playing a local guy by the name of
Isaiah Gadson I've actually known Isaiah
for quite some time not super well but I
think he was playing scholastic
tournaments at the same time I was all
the way back in fifth grades
we've both been doing this for a while
the game against Isaiah went d4 g6 c4
Bishop g7 and then just a quick note
about the opening night c3 is a
perfectly fine move but sometimes people
do this annoying thing with c5 and
Bishop takes c3 and I've never bothered
to figure out what I'm supposed to do
here
it's supposed to be good for white but
I've just never bothered to figure it
out so I play Knight f3 I move three
against this move order Knight f6 now I
play Knight to c3 the diagonals blocked
so I'm not worried about that line
anymore d6 d4 castles Bishop e2
five castles and now a knight bd7
which is looks like the the fourth most
popular line in the Kings Indian here
of course the main line goes with knight
c6 and d5 and 97 and then you know white
does this and black does this and white
gets checkmated but he's up a rook so he
gets to feel good about it but in the
game night be d7 and so this is a line I
I knew a little bit about I wasn't a
hundred percent certain of all of the
theory
I knew that Bishop III was a move I knew
that rook e1 was a move I thought Queen
c2 might be a move but I wasn't sure and
I knew that d5 was kind of bad so I
wasn't gonna play that one but I just
chose Bishop e3 in the game now my
opponent played Knight g4 I knew that
the idea after nine g4 was to play
Bishop g5 and after f6 I had some vague
idea that you could come back to any of
these three squares
I chose d2 not knowing it was like the
main line my opponent played Knight h6
and now this is really where I I pause
to think for a while let's try and come
up with some some ways to play for white
here first and foremost though I want to
talk a little bit about Bishop d2 before
you make any decisions here why the d2
square for the bishop it seems like the
worst of the three options right you
kind of block in your queen you your
knight can no longer use this square
what why put this bishop on such a
stupid look at square
not so much queen c1 isn't really my
idea here with Bishop d2 not so much for
example immediately I'll just say Knight
f7 is what my opponent wants to play
anyways supporting the center
I'm sorry to say that one more time this
C pawn I'm confused
oh you're talking about having this no
not not quite not quite that well let's
examine first the downsides to Bishop c1
because to my eyes this is actually the
most natural move bringing the bishop
all the way back but the downside is
that okay let's say just for example
Knight back to h6 is played again and
now you play a move like d5 yeah let's
say d5 and let's say I move like a5 you
play a 395 you can't play b4 here this
is a huge downside to Bishop c1 you
cannot play b4 here because this is now
a pin the bishops in the way and I think
this is the main reason why Bishop d2 is
the main move you just interfere with
your own pieces like this and this turns
out to be very very relevant so in the
game I wanted to make use of the fact
that I had not put the bishop back on c1
so I took on c5 took an e5 rather my
opponent took on e5 and then what move
do you think I played here
taking advantage of the fact that my
bishops on d2 and Nazi one
so yeah 95 is actually a key idea in the
position for white and you can bring
this Bishop out to to be for to look at
some of these dark squares but the
problem with 95 is black has a distinct
advantage in the pawn structure actually
of course white has committed to both
Eve 4 and C 4 the black is only
committed to e5 so he still has this
option of c6 remaining and this is
actually kind of the the crux of blacks
plays blacks trying to say you don't
have the d5 square and I do have the d4
square this is this is what black is
trying to person 95 you're going to hit
with c6 unfortunately but the move I
played taking advantage of the fact the
ship is out here is actually b4 and now
let's examine what the difference would
be just to back up one more time if I
played Bishop c1 in the same line and I
played b4 here
what would blacks response be black is a
very good move here
no remember what's the problem with the
bishop on c1 it interferes and
interferes right so black can take
advantage of this
yeah it's it's a five of course you
can't play a three due to the pin and so
you have to play an awkward looking move
like either be five or even Bishop a
three and now the problem is you're
giving up the c5 square this is what the
move before is is aimed at attaining the
move before once to take the be 5 square
and you're going to give it up if you
give up this be for pawn and so in the
in the game line after Bishop d2 that h6
takes takes b4 now against a 5 of course
we'll just be playing a3 immediately you
know I'm not against playing in this
position at all where black is actually
the one giving up the a file so b4 is
the big point to my opening play here at
the bishop on d2 supports this idea and
this is the type of logical chess that
you that you want to kind of strive for
it helps to already know some of these
ideas going in it's tough to kind of
divine these at the board sometimes but
just take note of where you've put your
pieces and what the differences are
between your various options and then
try and make the most effective use of
it so this Knight comes back to f7 it's
a pretty natural move guards the g5
square card it's a 5 in preparation for
a move like f5 later on and now I simply
continued gaining space on the Queen
side with c5 my opponent played c6
putting an end to my Knight d5 ideas
this Queen comes out to be three just
its natural to get the Queen off the
open file and this supports the the
Queen side push as well Queen c7 by my
opponent and now I simply play Bishop e3
guarding this pawn a little bit more
thoroughly rook d8 rook d1 and now
Knight f8 is my opponents play I took
advantage of this open D file that my
opponent kind of gave me of course
though I do want to mention black is
still sticking to this plan black wants
to put the knight on e6 in the knight on
d4 and also perhaps you know develop
this bishop
see sixes as well so in the meantime I
simply take on d8 take on d8 rook d1
Queen e7 and now let's see if you guys
can find the next key move for white
here this is kind of what the play has
been culminating in if you'll notice all
of my my previous moves have been
bringing pieces towards this this Queen
side
so yeah b5 is actually totally totally
right you you can't really just get
complete control over this square
because black is not going to take on on
b5 that'd be that'd be it a little bit
foolish what black did do in the game
it's good the bishop develops so I moved
the Queen and now 98 to defend on the c6
and now of course I simply take on c6 to
gain a long-term structural advantage
and now in the game I was looking at my
position knows I was feeling pretty good
about myself here it looks like white
just has slightly more space on this
Queen side and I was hoping that I could
prove a pretty distinct advantage with
with that turns out though black isn't
doing totally horribly here for example
in the game I just put an ID - you know
rerouting the final piece over to this
Queen side now
he played Knight d7 and I suddenly
noticed that hang on a second that's one
attacker that's that's two attackers
this is gonna be three attackers this is
gonna be four attackers he's actually
quite well placed to uh to challenge the
c5 pawn for the immediate moment I
simply defended it and then he added
another attacker with Bishop f8 so
Bishop f8 of course putting more
pressure on to this pawn he's still not
threatening to to capture it immediately
but perhaps if I do nothing starting to
take here and now there are simply three
attackers here if Knight a4 actually
maybe rook b8 in night b7 and oh my
goodness so many attackers I don't want
to count so after Bishop f8 let's see if
you guys can can come up with a move
that I played here
can you come up with the move I don't
think the line I just showed was quite
the most accurate for black by the way
but we'll roll with it here you get the
general idea Black's
flex trying to put a ton of pressure on
this pawn and hoping that I will crumble
Eirik d6 uh yeah Rick t6 is actually a
pretty good move it keeps up the edge a
little bit
probably queenie 8 is as a problem you
have to solve here just keeping an eye
on all the pieces blacks position is
nothing if not compact but it yeah Rick
t6 isn't a bad move at all you could
probably end up just repeating or maybe
trying to claim you slightly improve the
position of your ex somehow or maybe
even go for like an exchange sacrifice
with some crazy business like this you
know it's it's not so easy though when
you're at the board you don't want to
just give away these rooks you know they
matter to you
see youtube chat no good ideas from
YouTube chat somebody in YouTube wants
to play Bishop c4 what do you guys think
about Bishop c4 you hate it I hate it
too good job you don't want to trade off
pieces when your opponent's behind in
space it just makes their position
easier to play black could take play 96
and you're just improving his attack
yeah he does have three attackers but
the queen is a little bit awkwardly
placed to take on c5
nine a five well this one does give up
this pawn and I'm not so sure we're
thrilled about this development here
this I don't see myself winning this
chess game very easily especially
because a two hangs but okay
ninety five not not a horrible idea
no horrible idea putting more pressure
all right
I'll change the question and maybe then
you'll find the move instead of trying
to find white to move and defend the C
pawn try to find white to move and win
white to move and win the punish Black's
lack of space
yeah someone in YouTube has it someone
in YouTube good job Louis of course I'm
sure he's done all the necessary
calculation for it to f4 is a little bit
beside the point here the the plays
revolving around this this kind of
tension between these pawns in
particular not so much around this epon
queen a3 defends upon but doesn't win
we're trying to win the game
anybody know well maybe losing pieces
just your achieving a winning position
here there's one move that it's like
plus four for white don't don't
fact-check me
everybody in youtube has it now the now
that I literally told them I just talked
about ninety-five my play it takes you
it takes you ninety-five Tristan you get
the gold star 95 losing a piece
everybody loves losing pieces so there
that's the best type of winning move so
black takes on d5 and now I resign but
no what what what do I do here simply
recapture right you take back and you
have fewer Knights but now you have more
pawns so that's the good news if a
simple move like Bishop f7 then I think
most things are winning here
particularly you can start with c6 or d6
let's just start with d6 and these pawns
are just kind of crashing through let's
look at the more and the the more
testing line which is Bishop f5 now
there's one move here that keeps that
the total win in the position you're
absolutely winning if you play this move
in fact I did not play this move see I'm
not perfect
so there's only one way to keep the win
and if you'll notice it's the best move
to kind of displace the black pieces
that's your goal here you're you're
you're claiming that these two pawns are
worth the night because you're making
the black pieces so awkward and you're
taking away so many squares from them
that you're just gonna be able to push
them through to win so it's kind of
sensible this next move if you kind of
approach it with that thinking you want
to displace the black pieces as much as
you can so c6 not a bad idea but it
doesn't displace the black pieces as
much as you can let's see what was I
thinking after c6 though it's a valid
point I think simply Knight be you know
I think you have to I think you have to
take this
you can play pawn takes and now noun i
p8 I believe and we're putting a little
bit of pressure here
although wait a second this this looks
awful this looks terrible
okay I don't remember what's wrong with
c6 ah ok what about Queen before after
c6 this was what I was worried about in
the game of course you can trade Queens
you can even push c7 or take this Knight
but at the end of the day remember you
only have a pawn for for the piece that
you lost and so here you do have this
strong deep own and maybe a slight edge
and maybe more than a slight edge but
you know black is kind of surviving
black is surviving Tristen two gold
stars in one night g4 this Bishop is the
key piece for black defending this this
queening diagonal and so after g4 of
course this Bishop has to move and it
can't go to e6 can't go to these squares
so it has to go to c2 and then the the
nice follow-up for white takes advantage
of this King as well and you play d6 now
the most natural move is actually Queen
e8 to keep an eye on the squares in
front of the pawns the Queen and of
course loses now to Queen c4 check
and so Queen f7 would be forced and now
something like Bishop c6 even further
miss places these black pieces putting
more things on this diagonal now simply
rook d2 you really can't take this
Knight otherwise this is just dead and
so maybe Bishop e4 and now c6 and all of
these black pieces are just kind of
tripping over themselves and this is
just completely crushing for white what
I played in the game is actually d6
hitting the Queen first and now after
Queen e8 g4 is obviously less good
because of Bishop e6 when now instead of
white getting this diagonal black black
it's the diagonal so g4 would have been
really really nice but I played d6
instead now Bishop e5 was my choice just
putting more pressure on this diagonal
Knight f7 trying to reroute and put
pressure on the d6 pawn I simply
continued with c6 and now my opponent
could have taken I would have taken here
and that was one way to play instead
Isaiah chose Knight b6 when after take
some b6 take some p6 I can play d7 and
kind of win a piece in this manner of
course if you play Queen d8 you'll get
hit with c7 and this rook is is going to
die going to die
so instead simply Bishop takes d7 pawn
text e7 and Queen d8 and turns out this
position is only like +2 so I'm I'm the
worst ever missed my chance with g4 now
I'm just playing for this this nice deep
on here and of course my Queens attacked
so I played Queen efore removing it from
the threat of capture King g7 was a very
nice move by my opponent stepping off of
this annoying diagonal that was the
source of so many problems for him I
played Queen d5 just trying to kind of
weasel my way in here create some
threats 96 attacks my bishop so I move
it rook b8 it's actually pretty
important for black to stay on this back
rank here otherwise you're gonna run
into some tactics with
Queeny six when this nights gonna gonna
be a text and Queenie eight might be
coming as well dangerous stuff dangerous
stuff so Rick p8 keeps the back rank a
little bit more solid
I played a four with the idea being I
need to get the knight into the game and
this pawns in the way so I'm gonna kill
it
my opponent played Knight f7 back which
is actually you know a really nice
defensive move he kept playing like
these moves that were like surprising
and good night f7 allows this Queen some
ability by guarding this d8 square
continued with Knight d2 trying to get
the knight into a better Square Queen
yz7 was his choice and I played Knight
c4 now after Queen c5 I kind of started
to to let things slip a bit
I played rook b1 and it turns out Knight
c4 probably wasn't the the greatest move
ever really rook b1 immediately and then
I have all the same threats except it's
coming through a bit more quickly I
haven't spent the time to play to play
this move Knight c4 and well kind of
actually see that happen in the game so
in the game I played rugby one here 98
attacks my bishop so I trade Queens and
play Bishop d5 and now my big idea is to
break through with a 5 this was kind of
my winning try and it turns out if I
just played rook b1 here now after Quinn
c5 takes takes I can play a5 immediately
so this is this is why my play was a
little bit inaccurate here I missed a
chance to just kind of break through
with this immediately of course we saw
nice before instead and now if I play a
5 here do you guys out whoa I'm sorry my
Bishop singing King f8 and now if I play
a 5 here how do you think black would
respond there's only one way one way for
black to respond
all other moves lose
yeah b5 is the key idea you need this
Bishop to defend this a7 square
otherwise you're just gonna you're just
gonna get killed this pawn just runs so
with that in mind I played the move rook
b5 making b5 illegal
kingi 7 was played now a5 thankfully b5
is still illegal
so King takes d7 and my original idea
was to play a 6 here but I found out
that my opponent is just in time with
the move Knight c6 and this was really
annoying to me because I I wanted to win
and knight c6 makes it hard to win he's
gonna put this knight on a 7 and it's
gonna be really difficult to to get any
any further than my a pawn so I kind of
switched up tactics here turns out well
first of all at this point my opponent
was in pretty severe time pressure and I
wasn't in super severe time pressure but
I was running out of time I played the
move Knight takes b6 trying to just play
with an advanced B pawn and a bishop
against tonight turns out the only way
to keep an edge is to take with the pawn
keeping more pieces on the board which
is kind of in line with with keeping
winning winning chances alive sometimes
instead though Knight takes c6 Bishop
takes pawn takes and I thought maybe I
had like just a total hold on the
position all my pieces kind of defend
each other and there was no way for
black to really get at this pawn
fortunately I was wrong I opponent very
quickly played Knight b7 I played g4
which is always a kind of a good move
and these types of event game x' you
want to take some space and keep the
Queen the King side pawns a little bit
stuck for the moment and it actually
came into play a little bit later on now
Knight d6 from my opponent simply rook
be for now Knight c8 and this was his
big maneuver in three short moves he's
already attacking my pawn so I play b7
to defend it
the knight comes back to d6
and then I realized that I have no way
to defend this pawn after king c7 um so
I played Rick Dees rook b6 king c7 I
gave that well I could have given the
check but he would have simply repeated
and so instead I played the move rook a
six and my idea was I'm gonna take on f6
if you take on b7 and try to win this
position turns out this is a very very
slight edge for a for white due to how
these pawns are kind of kind of
disjointed here although black should be
holding without too much difficulty
instead though my opponent was afraid of
me
so he played rook f8 defending this pawn
and I said oh my god thank God he played
to Rick f8 now I can try to win and so
I'll ask you to try and find the the
winning idea here from this position
it's it's kind of difficult it's kind of
difficult there's only one way to really
continue pressing for an advantage it's
a difficult idea but I'll let you try
and find it just a few minutes
I've seen a lot of rookie sevens a lot
of rookie eights in the YouTube chat one
rook c6 check 100k one it's not rookie
cuz it would be eight everybody wants to
play it one person really wants to play
trick c6 check but has no idea why so of
course rook e8 black is playing or a v8
in response to uh to keep to keep white
from from queening
now two people want to check them but
they still don't know why those works e6
do nothing well if it does something you
got to tell me what yeah tell me what
so yes
well okay I'll play King d7 sure but
your pawns hanging Rick c6 King d7 your
pawns hanging right so you you have to
do something about it
move the rook back to a six mile for
your draw
how far down my goodness okay all right
first hint Rick c6 is correct rook c6 is
correct
but what's the idea
um so yeah of course I will mention the
obvious tactic if you take on B seventh
and then the night hangs so King d7
instead rooks e6 King D seven Bishop e6
check oh ha hanging all the pieces oh I
didn't see that one
if it were illegal for blacks to take
the white pieces Bishop e6 would be
really really powerful all right
I'll give you a hint attack this pawn
the hints are flowing it's only a matter
of time now
it's only a matter of time
rooks see it hangs your rook and your
pawn come on you guys guys are better
than this well we looked at that Michael
we look tricking it rook b8 was the
response
nobody knows nobody knows how to attack
an H pawn the move of course is rook c3
with an idea in the game my opponent
play direct b8 which loses to rook h3
now the point is if you want to capture
this guy we're gonna get hit with rook
age 7 and there are a number of ways to
play here perhaps simplest it's just
taking and uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh
everybody knows the triangle he's
outside the box
yep and so white is simply winning king
upon endgame so you can't take the pawn
you can't play something like h5 because
I'll simply take it and after takes and
takes you have the same problem with
this H pawn and after if you don't take
on on visa and then I mean this is just
gonna be this is gonna be so sad this is
gonna be so so sad
you can't stop both pawns and you're
never really threatening to take b7
anymore because what white has this nice
H pawn which is passed so in the game my
opponent tried rook h8 does everybody
see the move after a KH 8 to end the
game I played this move in black
resigned
the chapters
you got it and rook takes h7 and black
resigns here and you can't take the rook
white will simply queen and this is this
is over and if you I mean obviously the
rock itself is hanging as well so Rick
takes h7 was was the end of this game so
this one had a lot of ups and downs in
it but this 95 move was a really nice
idea hopefully you get a chance to play
move like that and one of your games I'd
like to say I just totally invented it
over the board but I think I had seen
some some kind of similar idea and some
famous game I have no idea which one or
when but it wasn't totally new to me but
it's definitely one to keep in mind if
you can get this fluid pawn Center kind
of rolling up the board it's it's worth
quite a lot the main danger as what you
saw happen in the game is that by giving
up a full piece for a pawn like this a
lot of the time your opponent can just
give it back in a pretty nice manner
like Bishop takes d7 pawn takes d7 and I
still had a nice advantage probably
should have been winning but it's a lot
more difficult than that it feels like
it should be so always be wary of your
opponent giving the material back is
it's kind of what happened in this game
any questions on this game all right
well I think that just about does it for
the road to 2000 tonight yeah just a
quick recap the key ideas don't be lazy
at the board calculate to completion
it's really really important and that's
a very common mistake quite often is
just not calculating to the ends not
because you can't but sometimes because
you don't want to so be on the lookout
for that in your games and then in this
game as well a lot of key ideas
revolving around using extra space you
know don't trade off pieces and then
look for this this nice breakthrough
look for ways to make your opponent's
pieces less coordinated
all right with that thank you very much
for joining me this week on the road to
2000 my name is Caleb Denby and I will
see you next time
[Music]
you